Friday has come at last and in addition
to dawdling tarrying and generally
slouching towards the weekend to be born
you're watching gamespot news it's june
fifth and i'm chris waters here to run
down the top five stories of the week
for you these are chosen by pageviews
number of comments and up votes and most
importantly my capricious whims which
stories will i deign to put in front of
you today let's find out batman arkham
knight is one of this month's biggest
releases and we got some new details
about the game earlier this week
starting a new game plus will allow you
to keep all your gadgets in XP so you
can access certain areas earlier and
continue your hunt for the Riddler
trophies that may have eluded you on
your first time through also there will
be quote no loading screens as you play
through the whole game no loading
screens but when am I going to check my
facebooks and my tweeters my instant
grams and games have really changed you
know changes are afoot any magical
marketplace of steam which rolled out a
new leaf onto policy on Tuesday
customers can now return games and dlc
within two weeks of purchase provided
they haven't played the content in
question for more than two hours you
just gotta fill out a form on steam's
website and wait about a week for
approval valve also announced that you
can now pre-order steam machines steam
link and that ambitious steam controller
that aims to do everything a keyboard
and mouse and controller can do and also
looks like an owl face hey if I can
comfortably use that thing to play Forex
strategy games to my couch as it claims
to allow I'm going to be pretty stoked
and also sleep deprived the pre
three-game announcement game was strong
this week with a bunch of publishers
teasing their wares and promising to
show more at e3 in just over a week
uncharted the Nathan Drake collection
rounds up Nate Edie's first three
adventures and displays them at 1080p 60
frames per second drake's Fortune among
thieves and drake's Deception will be
arriving on the ps4 on october 9th as a
part of the collection golden Abyss
Nathaniel's vita outing it was not
invited but there will be a bonus in the
form of first access to the
uncharted 4 multiplayer beta do we all
pretty much agree that uncharted two
among thieves was the best one cool just
checking kicking off the week with a
surprise reveal and a sweet trailer to
boot was XCOM 2 did you know x com
stands for extreme clobbering of moon
men it doesn't but it totally should the
sequel will take place 20 years after
enemy Unknown in a world in which
everyone has surrendered to the aliens
everyone that is except you and your
squad of guerrilla fighters and your
science friends and your hover base XCOM
2 is set to arrive on pc in november no
word yet on console versions the biggest
story of the week say with me now giant
cow demon patched into witcher 3 just
kidding it's fallout 4 fallout 4 is real
there's a media announcement trailer and
everything we've got a big time trailer
breakdown posted on the site if you want
to delve for details but it's going to
be set in Boston it's coming only to pc
xbox one and playstation 4 and there is
no release date announced expect more
fallout 4 goodness during Bethesda's III
press conference on sunday June
fourteenth and with that it's all over
but the crying I'll miss the times we
had this weekend wish you the best next
week as hostess with the mostest Jess
McDonald returns to the GS news scene
actually she'll be filming here in San
Francisco so who knows we may meet again
until such time as that take it easy and
have a great weekend
you